[Music]
xidrate comes in a little glass vial
[Music]
yes i'm going to look like this for the
entire video yes i know this is not in
any way accurate cosplay i don't have
the correct jacket and my hair is not
long enough and the color is the wrong
color don't care this is what you get
and if you know the movie i'm talking
about you get what i'm doing and if you
don't
i don't know i look like
a knockoff of diamond haagen but anyways
i've had a list of things that i wanted
at some point to just ramble on about
because i just really enjoy them
and i've had that list sitting around
for a while um
and then
it got reminded to me that maybe i
should pick out something uh somewhat
seasonal
given that it is
almost halloween
thanks for the reminder carowind so yes
because of that i'm now going to talk
about
repo the genetic opera
a
horror
rock opera
which is a film that
i
adore
and also know why
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
of people don't like it at all like this
is this is a cult movie in the purest
sense it was made by a bunch of people
passionate about the idea for a niche
audience that it didn't find it flopped
when it came out it eventually found
that audience over time on home video
but let me tell you
i get why this bombed
that makes 100 sense to me that this
thing did not land with general
audiences
and this is definitely a film that
i am probably going to list a whole
bunch of reasons why it's probably not
for you
and if any one of the things i talk
about makes you go oh i'm not sure i
want to watch that you know what that's
fair
i'm not going to sit here and go oh you
should overlook that watch anyway
if if what i'm about to talk about
sounds bad to you you probably won't
like it but you know what
my friends
this
is my trash
this is a film made in 2008 and starring
a
incredibly talented cast and that
includes such luminaries as anthony
stewart head yes giles from buffy the
vampire slayer alexa penavaga who
most people at this point still know as
the older sister from the spy kids
movies legend of the stage sarah
brightman
horror icon bill moseley an actual flat
out rock star with nivek ogre from
skinny puppy and
in her finest performance no sarcasm
paris hilton
no matter what you think about her as a
person or as an actress she is god damn
perfect for the part she's in so is
everybody else everybody really wants to
be here and all of this pulled together
and directed by darren lynn boseman who
directed no less than four saw films he
in fact filmed saw four while the
musical pre-record for this movie was
being done so what we have here folks is
a violent vicious over-the-top
in-your-face and absurd
movie
the core concept at the heart of this is
that the entire film is set in a future
where organ transplants have become so
easy
that they're actually done as fashion
statements
they're still very expensive but that's
okay
you can get your new organs on a on a
payment plan but if you miss a payment
the repo man will be sent around to
reclaim geneco's property this might
sound familiar there was another
non-musical and far less interesting
film called repo men starring jude law
and forest whitaker this is much better
or at the very least this is much more
unique
certainly compared to that so
in this world we have anthony stewart
head
playing nathan wallace
the repo man a man with a tortured past
he tried to save his wife from a severe
blood condition but
his treatment that he was sure would
work instead killed her and now he is
left with their young daughter who
inherited that same genetic condition
as the repo man he works for roti largo
head of the largo family owner of gene
co played by paul sorvino of goodfellas
fame largo has three
monstrous children the insanely violent
luigi the
viciously narcissistic pavi and the
surgery addicted amber sweet
nathan's daughter shiloh is now 17 and
very eager to get out of the house even
though
it's not
safe
outside throw into the mix the famous
opera singer blind mag who owes her eyes
to gene cohen therefore they effectively
own her
here's the main thing that i love about
this
as far as rock operas go
this leans into the opera part of that
way harder than i have seen most things
do generally rock operas they have a
tendency to basically come across like
rock albums with a plot
which
kind of owes to their roots as being
concept albums back in the back in the
60s and 70s before they actually started
getting staged or filmed
but this
yes it's rock yes it's opera in the
sense that almost no line of dialogue is
just spoken and not in some way sung
but honestly the way in which is opera
is the scale and the absurdity of it
this is everything up to operatic
proportions this is every emotion
requires being belted to the back of the
theater nothing is small everything is
huge and grand no matter how
silly it is the film jumps from songs
that sound like this
[Music]
two ones that sound like this
[Music]
[Applause]
and it does not miss a beat because the
thing to remember about opera real opera
classic opera is they are tragedies
tragedies of love revenge death
generations falling apart all of that's
here and all of it
is dripping
in blood and viscera because there's uh
more than a few scenes that are frankly
gratuitous organ removals well i say
gratuitous they're there for the sakes
of justifying the songs and that's
another thing there's a whole bunch of
things about this movie that if i were
to apply my normal critical spectrum to
it i would have legitimate issue with
there's a whole bunch of songs that
don't move the story forward don't
really tell us all that much new about
the character singing them
and yet are here anyway and the scenes
that are in these songs well that wasn't
really necessary
songs like night surgeon and even the
iconic xidrit anatomy don't really do
much to move the plot forward heck the
grave robber himself played by
co-screenwriter taryn zunik
is frankly overdeveloped he adds almost
nothing to the story he does a bit of
exposition at the front end a little bit
at the back end but that is exposition
that's largely
unnecessary and yet he gets way more
screen time and way more songs than a
character who does not actually actively
impact the plot should be granted
there's these comic book interludes to
give us backstory which are cool and
actually the way the whole thing opens
is comic book ask and i'll kind of come
back to that but the thing is it's
clearly there to fill in audiences who
were confused by just
their they weren't totally following all
the relationships of the characters
involved in the thing and so these
little interludes are there to cover the
backgrounds of a number of the key
characters and that's fine as far as
fixes go except you can tell they
weren't initially meant to be there
because later on songs will relay the
exact same information that was in the
comic book stuff just maybe slightly
more roundabout and less overt
the tone is all over the place it will
go from slapstick style comedy to
vicious literally gut-wrenching gore at
the drop of a hat and all of these are
things that under normal circumstances
i will probably dock
points i don't do points but if i did
points on a rating i dock points for
these but not here
the thing is this is not a movie meant
to be judged in the way other movies are
judged and i don't think that's just me
making excuses because like i said this
thing is very upfront with its
intentions to be huge and operatic and a
big thing about opera is that it be
emotionally true
not logistically true
and as long as it has enough energy to
barrel through any bumps in the road i'm
not going to say any of the things that
i just cited aren't faults but this
thing has such energy i don't care
i feel like that is the epitome of
something that i identify as my trash
more than anything else
doesn't have problems sure but boy do i
not care now i mentioned the opening it
does actually open with a series of
comic panels giving the background of
the world and then going to the grave
robber singing directly to camera
following the repo man as he bloodily
possesses some of geneco's property
now this is an incredibly efficient and
upfront way of laying out the film's
intentions and i think it was a very
good call
because it is
absurd and the comic book uh look of the
thing should give you a clue as to the
tone and the vibe and the level of
nonsense we're going for here and then
to immediately go into a kill of a
character who we don't know it does not
matter to the plot
that establishes this is what you're in
for
in a way it kind of reminds me of the
very first episode of black mirror which
was the national anthem now that episode
wasn't necessarily indicative of the
specifics of the material that black
mirror would tackle going forward but
what it did is it was so abrasive it
basically was a mission statement to
anyone watching saying in his very first
episode look if you can't handle this
you shouldn't be here
and i feel like the opening to repo is
basically doing the same thing but like
i said if you are turned off by this i
get it in fact
funny thing
first time i ever watched this movie
took me a little while to decide whether
or not i liked it
because there were some things throwing
me off mainly some of the tone shifts uh
particularly around characters like
luigi and pavi all due respect to bill
moseley he's not a singer like at all
they're not all great singers but most
of them can put enough energy and force
behind it that it works he really
doesn't and he has this scene with these
sound effects
[Music]
and i had really enjoyed stuff that had
gone on prior to that but then this
happened i'm like i don't know about
this but you know what
i got locked in
when this happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and that was the moment that i realized
oh
okay we are working on wagnerian levels
here we are going so big in every way
even when
even when we do comic relief that's
going to be bigger than it should be
just like the singing is going to be
bigger than it should be the violence is
going to be bigger than it should be
everything is bigger
than it should be
but i think the variety of things like
the injection of the comedy and the
shifting from flat out opera songs to
hard rocking songs to emotionally driven
songs to completely superfluous songs
that are still fun
that keeps it from getting boring
because it is true that if you just
crank everything up to 11 and keep it
there that actually gets dull it's
basically the same as staying at one
because
nothing ever wavers and while the level
of energy of this thing is pretty much
constant
what that energy is providing
that does shift and change it makes it
far more
enjoyable certainly for me
another thing worth pointing out this
thing is short i rewatched it just
before filming this and it's much
shorter than i thought it was it's 93
minutes not counting the credits
97 if you do count the credits
but it feels longer not because it's a
slog but because so
much is crammed into this thing it's
bursting at the seams and yet it doesn't
feel rushed because like any good opera
it is
incredibly simplistic story that it's
actually telling yes there's twists and
turns and motivations and this and that
but ultimately
it is a story of
family and revenge
and we all get that
heck on the note of family the very end
of this movie uh spoilers if you haven't
seen it varian in this movie has shiloh
forgiving her father
her father who
if you haven't seen the movie i should
point out
drugged her on a regular basis to make
her think that she had the disease her
mother had but she in fact does not he
was just doing that so that she could
never leave him and he wouldn't be left
alone and who also not only is employed
as the repo man to reclaim people's
organs and leave the rest of them to die
but it's has been demonstrated in a few
songs actually kind of enjoys doing it
as well
and his daughter forgives him
now
i have gotten very pissed
at things in the past
for pulling this well you have to
forgive them their family move but the
thing is this entire thing is ratcheted
up to such absurd levels i can't take it
seriously
i can't watch a movie where people are
regularly being disemboweled for no
story reason whatsoever and go boy i'm
really worried about the the lessons
that someone might take away from this
no
not this time and that's part of the
magic balance of this movie
that as committed as it is to absolutely
everything and it commits
at the same time
you can't
take any of it seriously and i think the
movie knows that nobody will take it
seriously but it's willing to take
itself seriously so you don't have to
now for one of a few points of criticism
there are a number of songs that
don't really work uh particularly well
even by the sliding scale that i kind of
grade this whole thing on 17 has a very
clear mission but it doesn't quite
resonate correctly and gold is a little
bit of a slog but i tell you what legal
assassin
night surgeon
chase the morning let the monster rise
things you see in the graveyard at the
opera tonight and of course
xydrate anatomy
these songs
[ __ ] rule
and there's something
really pure
about
the way that these songs
have the energy and the raucous nature
and our
propelling story and characters in
absurd ways
that honestly would never work for me if
this wasn't sung
these characters these events if this
was done straight i'd hate it but the
music elevates everything one because
it's awesome two because the energy of
the rock music is exactly what this
thing needs to go down smoothly
because without it this would this would
be a jagged mess i'd hate it i guarantee
you i would hate it if this was not a
musical so it's not the story it's not
the characters it's not even the the
aesthetic of the thing although
i have fun with all those ultimately it
is the music that carries this entire
thing so if you are wavering at all
check out the soundtrack go on spotify
and look it up give a listen
because i'll tell you what there are a
few things that will like latch on to me
as a song that goes hard and i can hear
the acting in it
[Music]
i'm a wannabe actor i'm a theater kid
i love hearing songs that aren't just
about sounding pretty it's about hitting
an emotion as hard as you frickin can
[Music]
and that's what this entire movie is it
is about hitting everything
that it does as
hard as possible
and that is why i will always
always love it
will i recommend it um
maybe to someone who i know
maybe someone who i know who i know well
enough to know whether or not they tune
into the wavelength of this thing but to
general audiences no hell no it's trash
but man oh man
is it ever my trash
have you seen
repo the genetic opera
if you have i want to hear what you
think about it and i want to hear your
favorite song something other than
xydrate anatomy that's the go-to pick
honestly my favorite probably at the
opera tonight but uh we started this
opera [ __ ] close second and if you
haven't seen it before
what's your impression of this insanity
what is your
absurd trash movie that works for the
halloween season feel free to share that
instead of or in addition
but whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it i have a patreon
if you care to support what it is i do
and the nonsense that you see before you
there are perks for every tier of
support like share and subscribe help me
out as well but
you don't have to
at the end of the day
you are the council
i'm just robbing the graves
and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and look at you
sticking around through the credits i
appreciate that well you know what
you're about to be treated to a whole
ton of names going by on the screen but
there's a few of them that i want to
give special attention to my special
thanks to bookworm jared boyce mj tracy
scrabbit vincent paul bartolucci kaelin
schwartz edelen hannah acker robin moore
ross schultz and shayla gourley if you
want to hear me mispronounce your name
check out the reward tears on the
patreon but for right now
thanks so much
[Music]
um
[Music]